un ecocardiograma es una prueba
frecuente que utiliza ondas de sonido
que de línea en la forma y el tamaño del
corazón de esta forma permite a su
médico ver cuán bien bombea sangre su
corazón y busca anormalidades en las
válvulas y cámaras del corazón
en un ecocardiograma trans torácico su
ecografista esparcir a un gel frío sobre
su pecho su ecografista movera con
firmeza un transductor a través del gel
enviando ondas de sonido indoloras a su
corazón las ondas de sonido rebotarán en
su corazón y regresarán como un eco al
transductor las ondas de sonido se
convierten en imágenes en movimiento de
los músculos cámaras y válvulas del
corazón en una pantalla de vídeo
un ecocardiograma doppler registra ecos
de las células sanguíneas la velocidad y
la dirección del flujo sanguíneo indican
cuán bien circula la sangre alrededor y
dentro del corazón un ecocardiograma de
esfuerzo evalúa imágenes del corazón
antes y después del ejercicio o después
de tomar medicamentos que simulan el
ejercicio en el corazón comparar los
resultados de su ecocardiograma antes y
después de la actividad ofrece a su
médico información sobre ciertos
problemas cardíacos como enfermedades de
las arterias coronarias que pueden
ocurrir solo por esfuerzo un
ecocardiograma transesofágico envía
ondas de sonido a través de un
transductor que recorre suavemente su
garganta mientras usted está sedado esta
prueba ofrece una evaluación más
detallada y precisa de su corazón